STEPHANIE WONG: Hey, everyone.
Thanks for joining.
My name is Stephanie
Wong, customer engineer
here, at Google.
And we have here, of
course, you know--
JONATHAN CHAM: Jonathan Cham.
STEPHANIE WONG: And welcome to
GCP Online Meetup number 38.
JONATHAN CHAM: 38!
STEPHANIE WONG: Yes!
JONATHAN CHAM: Yes!
STEPHANIE WONG: So we're
super excited today
because we have Addison
Howard over here from Kaggle.
And he is a program
manager, so he's
going to be talking
about everything
he knows about Kaggle, the
community involved in it,
and machine learning as well.
So I'm going to let him take
it away and introduce himself.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yes,
Addison, are you alive?
ADDISON HOWARD: Hello.
I am alive.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yes.
Alive and well.
ADDISON HOWARD: Live
from Denver, Colorado.
I'm go glad to be
a part of this.
I'm really excited.
Like Steph mentioned,
I'm Addison Howard.
I'm a program manager on Kaggle.
Kaggle's been a part of Google
now for about six months.
We are the home for data
science and I'm super
pumped to be a part of this.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
Thanks, Addison.
So, I mean, I don't know.
Stephanie, when the topic came
up, will they take our jobs?
I was a little concerned,
because I don't know.
Do you think our
jobs will be lost?
STEPHANIE WONG: I don't know.
I feel like I would be
pretty OK with having
half my job be covered
by an automated service.
I could put my feet up.
JONATHAN CHAM: That's true.
STEPHANIE WONG: Work part time.
JONATHAN CHAM: And part
time sounds pretty good.
It sounds pretty good.
But I mean, in
all seriousness, I
think the topic of automation,
and labor, and the economy,
and AI, and ML-- like how
all these things fit together
and the impact of it
is a serious concern.
And I mean, even politicians
are talking about it right now.
So I thought it was a
good topic to bring up.
And I know, Addison--
he's been dealing with
a lot of competitions,
a lot of work with
large companies
and small companies around
predictions, automations.
And I'm guessing, if
anybody knows the answer
to this, Addison, probably,
has at least the best idea
about what he sees
in the future.
ADDISON HOWARD: Yeah.
Well, we'll see,
because I would say
that the answer to
the question of,
will machine learning
take your job?
Is kind of a big, fat maybe.
I mean, when it comes
to the future of work
though, almost one
in every two jobs
do have a high risk of
being automated by machines.
Now when you say that, I always
think of like "Terminator"
or something like
that, but, no, it's
things that can be automated and
repeated over and over again.
But, on the flip side, machines
cannot do things that require
a novel approach or are
based on something that they
haven't seen many,
many times before.
So when you think
about it, I always
kind of find it
fascinating thing
that the term "data
science" itself didn't even
exist until 2008.
Gosh, I was a junior in
college, at the time,
and data science finally
came around as a term.
And it's really accelerated
in the past few years.
But you've already seen
it in some common things
in the world.
So think about
mail-- snail mail.
Back in the day,
somebody's job was
to look at every single
letter and say, well,
I think that's a one,
I think that's a seven,
and divide it up.
Well, now they have
machine learning algorithms
that will scan handwritten
numbers and sort them.
So that's an example
of something.
But now you take that
to a newer extent
and you're seeing machines that
can read retina scans of eyes.
And while one ophthalmologist
may look at a scan of an eye--
maybe 50,000 scans, over
the course of their career.
We are now training a
machine to do the same thing
in a matter of hours.
And so, overall, I will
say, it kind of depends.
But ultimately, always be
reminded that machines cannot
do things that require a
novel approach or is based
on something that they haven't
really seen many times before.
STEPHANIE WONG: Maybe the
different way to look at it
is that machines
aren't necessarily
replacing your jobs.
I mean, they might be
replacing portions of your job,
but it might be actually
saving you time,
so that you can be doing
more interesting work instead
of manual, repetitive tasks.
ADDISON HOWARD: Exactly.
In the example of medicine,
we're now freeing up the time
that many ophthalmologists
have from looking
at scans over and
over again, to, now,
being able to do more research
and do more ground breaking
things in the world.
JONATHAN CHAM: So I
see, with my customers,
that's exactly right.
Taking over the entire job or
entire role is pretty rare.
It's more about really helping
workers be more productive.
I mean, we still need
mailmen, but instead
of looking at numbers
and trying to figure out
what zip code it is,
they're actually putting
mail inside of your mailbox.
ADDISON HOWARD: Right.
Or they're looking
at other ways to be
more efficient with their
shipping, and routes,
and things like that.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
JONATHAN CHAM: Cool.
So that's what I mean.
I guess that's the
net of the answer.
I'd love to hear from
the audience what
your thoughts are on this--
have you seen an
impact yourself?
What are your thoughts, in terms
of the impact on the economy?
I'd love to hear
what you guys think.
But I mean, Addison, I know you
had a couple other things you
wanted to go through.
ADDISON HOWARD: Yeah.
JONATHAN CHAM:
What does Kaggle do
and how has it impacted
the industry, as a whole?
Because I feel like it has.
ADDISON HOWARD: Sure.
So Kaggle is known as
the home of data science.
The fun of fact is the
term Kaggle is, literally,
just a amalgamation
of sounds that didn't
have a domain name taken yet.
And that's how
Kaggle came to be.
There's some fun,
internal, team folklore
around what the other
alternative would have them,
but it's basically become
the home of data science.
Originally, we kind of
came into the market
about six or seven years
ago, running machine learning
competitions, where our
CEO, Anthony Goldbloom,
wanted to predict the
results of Eurovision.
Are you familiar
with Eurovision?
It's the kind of the big,
"American Idol" style
competition, where
every country in Europe
sends a representative.
And there's sort of some
alliances and things
like that occur.
Well, they wanted to host
a competition to do that.
And that quickly
expanded to people
coming to Kaggle to learn
how to do data science.
Again, data science hasn't
been around for, really,
much more than a decade.
And a lot of people who
are currently in, usually,
the engineering community,
maybe computer science
community, maybe
mathematical community,
are wanting to get
involved in this.
And there isn't a whole
lot of research out there--
or there wasn't at the time.
And like many of us can likely
relate to, one of the best ways
to learn is to go figure
it out and try it out.
And so through competitions,
what ended up happening
is four people interested in
data science on the community
side--
people will come and have
a really unique problem
they can then go test
their knowledge on.
I'm trying to predict X,
I'm trying to guess Y--
we'll go through a couple
of those here, in a bit.
On the business side of the
house, what we're seeing
is a lot of companies.
They don't have a big
data science group yet.
Maybe they have
one or two folks,
maybe they don't
have some, maybe they
do have a couple of dozen
people who are data scientists.
And they're saying,
we've been trying
to solve a couple
of problems, but we
need some help, we need to then
through it over to a community.
And Kaggle now has--
we think we've just
surpassed 1.3 million people
in our community, who have come
to Kaggle saying, we want to do
more, we want to learn more.
STEPHANIE WONG: Wow.
ADDISON HOWARD: And
since competitions, we've
now started adding in things
like datasets and kernels.
Datasets being-- you always
hear about 80% of the work
is just cleaning up and
munging data together,
this now provides a wide
variety of data for people
to look at, and play
around with, and analyze.
And then kernels-- which we
can get into later, as well--
is a bit of code
sharing platform.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
I think one of the
daunting things about it
is trying to do something
by yourself, especially
when it comes data
science, if you have little
to no experience.
So just having that
community forum and people
to validate your creations
with is something
that we haven't really seen in
the industry, like you said,
a decade before or even
just the past few years.
JONATHAN CHAM: So outside of
the obvious reason why a company
or organization
would use Kaggle--
and the obvious reason
would be like, hey,
I want to hedge my bet on
instead of hiring a bunch of ML
data scientists, I want to
see if this is even plausible
or feasible, let me
put out an aware--
like $10,000-- see what
the results look like.
I mean, I feel like
that's the main reason why
people use Kaggle.
Are there any other
reasons, outside of that,
Kaggle would be useful
for, for an organization?
ADDISON HOWARD: Yeah.
So two to come to mind--
one is a fresh perspective.
So for example, one competition
that we're currently running
is Zillow--
The Zillow competition.
If you're familiar with Zillow,
they have the Zestimate.
And some people kind of maybe
complained, saying, oh, well,
that's not how much
my house is worth.
JONATHAN CHAM: I'm just
saying, that's definitely
wrong for my house.
It's way too low.
ADDISON HOWARD: And Zillow
is saying, yeah, we know,
we get it.
We understand it's
not always correct
and we want to do better.
And so they have a
team of data scientist
that have been working on this
algorithm and working on it.
And there are some
things that are
more technical around
overfitting or tweaking
the same thing until the
point where it doesn't
become very useful anymore.
They said, we have a
big team, but let's
get some fresh eyes
on this and see,
is there more meat
left on the bone
to get some value out of this
algorithm we're creating?
I think that's one common area.
And a second area
is novel approaches.
For those who are familiar
with machine learning,
there's sort of been
different trends
across the industry around
what techniques are useful.
So a big, popular
one in the beginning
was called Random Forest.
But there's other ones that
come up throughout the years,
but Kaggle's kind
of been the place
where those have been elevated.
And so one of the really big,
common ones now is XGBoost.
JONATHAN CHAM: I was just
going to mention that.
ADDISON HOWARD: Exactly.
JONATHAN CHAM: I
don't know what it is,
but I hear it everywhere.
ADDISON HOWARD: Exactly.
And that's something that
has really kind of come
to the forefront
as being something
that's useful, through Kaggle.
Because, like you mentioned,
it's such a big community.
Instead of it just
being somebody holding
onto their methodology, they're
still win the competition,
but then they'll say, hey,
guys, here's what I did.
Data scientists,
here's my methodology.
I tried this new technique.
Why don't you guys
play around with it
and see what you can
do with it as well?
STEPHANIE WONG: What has the
community generally looked at,
from what you've seen, in
terms of how teams are formed
and the people that are
really interested in getting
involved in contests?
Are they students?
Are they professionals?
ADDISON HOWARD: Yeah.
It's kind of a mix of both.
One cool thing that
we've recently released
is, actually, a
university-style platform,
like university method, where
a lot of teachers are saying,
we could really teach data
science well in our classroom
with a competition type format.
And so we have
something called InClass
that is, pretty much,
just for students to have
that type of learning ground.
But on the same
side, it's really
a wide variety of people from
all types of backgrounds that
come to be a part of Kaggle.
And so what we see is,
as competitions start,
people start--
discussion forums are very,
very prevalent for us.
And people start
flooding them with, hey,
I found these three articles
that might be helpful.
Hey, this is my professional,
educational background,
anybody want to be on my team?
And we'll literally see
people saying, sure,
message me, I'm in Germany.
I'm in Bangladesh.
I'm in Hawaii.
Let's create a team together.
And it's cool to see
people who have never
met each other in person--
and sometimes they will
win the competition,
and when I introduce them
to one of these clients,
they're meeting for the
first time, via video call.
Because they're just saying,
hey, I'm here to learn
and I want to be able to
learn from anybody, no matter
where they are, skill-wise
or geographically.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
I know some companies are using
it as a recruiting platform,
actually.
ADDISON HOWARD: Yeah.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
ADDISON HOWARD: It's
actually pretty neat.
I mean, a lot of the
big players have--
I say big players because
a couple of them--
they were pre-acquisition
and maybe there
might be some brands that
would be rivals to us.
But no.
So you can look at our website.
You see Walmarts, and
Facebooks, and All States
have come to us on a very
regular basis, saying,
this is a great
way for us to have
almost like an
accelerated job interview.
Instead of putting
them in a room
and making them do
a quick hackathon,
let's give them three
months to go figure
out what they can
go do, and give them
a problem similar
to what they would
do on a regular basis
that can attract people
who are interested, and
give them a day in the life.
STEPHANIE WONG: Cool.
I actually have a
question from online.
Do you know how community
engagement is encouraged?
I mean, besides
just, organically,
how people comment and want
to be involved in a project.
But are there other
interesting ways
that you've tried to
encourage different community
topics to be discussed
or people to start voting
on different solutions?
ADDISON HOWARD: Yeah.
So I will say, a majority
of it is organic.
For some people,
they're incentivized
by that we actually
have rankings.
So we have rankings to say
how good of a competitor
are you, how good of a kernel
author, code sharing person
are you, and how good of a
discussion person are you.
And you can get
different rates based off
of expert, master, grand master.
We have occasional
private competitions, just
for our masters
and grandmasters.
And I think a lot of it is
that people just, genuinely,
come to learn and people,
genuinely, come to--
hey, I can share.
If I share my knowledge
here, then somebody else
can maybe glean off
that and expand upon it.
And so we've,
occasionally, actually
offered some prizes
for best kernels,
best new datasets to
continue that engagement.
But I've been very surprised
and very pleased at,
really, how organic
that has been, as it is.
STEPHANIE WONG:
You were telling us
earlier about the
Twitter conversations
that you have right now
about machine learning.
ADDISON HOWARD: Yeah.
STEPHANIE WONG: So can you
talk about that a little bit?
ADDISON HOWARD: Yeah.
It's been pretty neat.
A full team of ours, at Kaggle,
is just a community team
that's looking for ways
to continue to get people
involved, both inside
competitions-- which, again,
what we kind of had been
known, historically, but now,
as we've expanded to become
truly a broader home for data
science--
and so the past three weeks--
and we have one
coming up next week.
I'm actually not sure how
many more we after that,
coming into the holidays.
But we've been hosting
debates on Twitter
that have been posing a
certain problem or a question
within data science and
saying, let's talk about this.
And so the very first one
we had was with, actually,
a guy that used to be a Kaggle
grand master discussion expert.
And then we, basically, poached
him from our own community
and brought him on board.
And was answering the question,
OK, AI, what's the hype?
Where's that over-hype?
Where's the under-hype?
What can it really accomplish?
Last week, we had another one
with our committee members,
talking about bias and
biased machine learning.
One example, if you're
not familiar with that,
would be if I were to
create an algorithm that's
trying to take stock
photo pictures of people
in professions and say, OK,
is this a doctor or a lawyer,
but if every picture of a
doctor that I bring in there
is an old white guy,
then, all of a sudden,
the algorithms only think
that doctors are all old,
white guys.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
ADDISON HOWARD: And so there's
a lot of questions around bias
that's been recurring.
And one that just happened last
night with one of our community
leads was, which
is more important--
the algorithm or the data?
Is having a good
algorithm, but bad data,
or vise versa going to get
you better or worse results?
And we were talking
through that.
And we've been hosting
those every Tuesday.
You can follow the hashtag--
#MLDebate.
I believe that's what it is.
And you can check out
our Twitter account
and see that as well.
JONATHAN CHAM: Cool.
Yeah.
I forgot what podcast, but
I was listening to something
about how sometimes
ML can perpetuate
negative stereotypes.
ADDISON HOWARD: Right.
JONATHAN CHAM: Right.
And sometimes it's
very controversial.
So it's just really interesting.
ADDISON HOWARD: And to kind
of elaborate on that, what's
interesting about those
problems is sometimes
you just don't have
you the capability
to get all the
[INAUDIBLE] you want.
Especially if you're
starting working with humans,
it's hard to get a very
true, representative sample.
So we need to often be conscious
that machine learning isn't
always designed to be
the perfect solution,
but maybe creating an algorithm
is to go from step zero
to eight and then maybe
take the rest by getting it
from eight to 10.
JONATHAN CHAM: So we do have
a question from the chat.
Can you cover how someone
with no ML experience
could use Kaggle?
I'll answer that from my
perspective and, Addison, maybe
I'll let you answer--
maybe Stephanie.
So I actually had
no ML experience
when Google acquired
Kaggle, so I went to Kaggle.
First of all, what is Kaggle?
And then I noticed
that, OK, it's bunch
of competitions of something.
But then I got really
interested in it.
Basically, there's
a problem statement
and you have to solve it, right?
ADDISON HOWARD: Right.
JONATHAN CHAM: So what I did was
I went into these competitions.
I started looking at all these
things called kernels, which
are kind of like open
notebooks that people write in
to develop some kind of
algorithm or software,
to help, basically,
take the dataset that's
provided by the customer and
do some manipulation, modeling,
and training on it.
And the ability to look
through, basically,
hundreds of peoples' notebooks
and look at how they take
a perspective on the problem--
that's how I learned about ML.
I'm definitely not the
expert, but it was just
a wealth of knowledge sitting
in all these Jupyter Notebooks.
So maybe I'll have--
Stephanie?
And then I'll let
Addison answer that.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
No, I agree with that.
I mean, I think I'm also getting
started with learning much
more about machine
learning and how
to leverage a lot of the
tools that people are using.
And being able to see
and learn from example
is key, as you said,
because it just difficult
to start with nothing.
And I don't even know where
to get started sometimes.
A lot of it can
go over your head.
So having those example
datasets and what
people have thought
of, out of the box,
is just incredibly helpful.
And I'm sure Addison will
agree with that as well.
JONATHAN CHAM: And
just one more note--
the top rated kernels
usually have very, very, very
good documentation, meaning
that the person took the time
to write out exactly what
that person did and why.
And so, I mean, just
reading all of that
is a good learning experience.
And there's a lot of comments,
a lot of community engagements,
which is why I think Kaggle's
a great place to learn ML.
So if you don't know
ML, actually, Kaggle
is the place to go.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
ADDISON HOWARD: Right.
JONATHAN CHAM: And if
you're awesome at ML,
it's also the place to go.
ADDISON HOWARD: Yeah.
I think you're right.
And you said it well.
I think it provides a lot
of opportunities based
on whatever level you're at.
I will say, just to play a
little bit of devil's advocate
against myself, if
you're coming in--
so I don't have a computer
developer background at all.
I'm more of a business guy.
And so I have experience in
math, econ, and that sort
of side of the house.
So I'm starting right now
and teaching myself Python.
So I'm getting
down to that level.
But a lot of times
you might say, OK,
I have this technical
skill, but I have nowhere
to apply it or test it.
We have a couple of different
introductory competitions,
as one way of doing that.
For example, the most popular
competition we've ever held
is one on the Titanic,
where we said, basically,
is this person going
to survive or not?
And you give them a whole list.
And so you can think, just
on an intuitive level.
Or what if you just
said, men don't survive,
women and children do.
You could probably
get 80% right.
Then maybe you start
toggling things,
like, OK, what if
they were wealthy?
What if they weren't?
What if they were on the
top part of the ship?
What if they weren't?
And that sort of gives
you the opportunity
to play around with that and
a very free, low ego, low risk
environment.
And we started having
more advanced things.
Can you predict housing prices,
in a non-Zillow sort of way?
If you want to get
more image recognition,
we have a competition for
that, but it's introductory.
So that's one of the best ways.
As Jonathan mentioned, kernels,
I think, are great as well.
Kernels, for us-- it's
not just code sharing,
but what we would
like to do is take out
a lot of the dependencies.
So if someone were to share
you their code otherwise,
maybe you go download all 16
of these different libraries,
and versions, and
things like that.
We try to remove a lot of that
to keep sharing pretty easy.
And then thirdly,
we're continuing
to develop out more tried and
true educational curriculum.
So we have a team that
is entirely rooted
in creating education-based
documentation
that we hope to be
releasing here soon.
JONATHAN CHAM:
That's really cool.
So I know we have
about 10 minutes left.
And we'll leave
some room for Q&A.
Do you mind just taking
a couple of minutes
to walk through
the user interface?
ADDISON HOWARD: Sure.
JONATHAN CHAM: I feel like,
for people who have never
looked or used Kaggle,
maybe you can show them
where the kernels are,
where the competitions are?
ADDISON HOWARD: Yeah.
Let me go ahead and
share my screen here.
I'll go back to where I was.
Shares.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
So while do that,
I mean, Stephanie,
how have you used Kaggle so far?
STEPHANIE WONG: So I actually
use it to try and find
public datasets that
people have already offered
or that we're already,
natively, on the site,
just so that I can have some
sort of way of testing out
my own creations.
And I've actually used it
on a workshop, as well.
JONATHAN CHAM: Oh, wow.
STEPHANIE WONG: Just to see
what we have available online.
So I've already found
it pretty useful
and I get email notifications
of different contests
that are being offered by other
commercial companies that are
offering contests and prizes.
So I do often see some
really interesting use cases.
For example, the Zillow one.
There's one for
holiday gift exchanging
and how you can
predict how someone
could get the right gift
that they've wanted.
JONATHAN CHAM: You
never get the right one.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
Some of them are fun.
It's interesting.
ADDISON HOWARD: Yeah.
It's been really great for us.
Now, being a part of
the Google team for,
I think, it's close to
being about nine months now,
actually, we had
the chance to be
have a little more
fun with competitions
and provide some more
unique items there, as well.
But log into Kaggle.
If you've already
logged into the page--
actually, let me see here.
I think I have the other
one pulled up as well.
So if you're not logged in--
are you seeing this new page?
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
ADDISON HOWARD: You get more
of this, what is Kaggle?
And you get things
like, hey, I'm
interested in a job, or some
very high level elements.
But OK, how can I learn
to do data science?
And talking about exactly
the same things we
were just mentioning--
surviving the Titanic.
They want to study some
benchmark models that
already exist.
We have plenty of blogs as well.
So we interview
previous winners.
So for example, this
data science bowl
was around heart disease.
And we interviewed
the winners and said,
what did you do to win?
JONATHAN CHAM: That's cool.
ADDISON HOWARD: We can
kind of talk through that.
So there's a wide variety
of ways and things
here that you can see.
We're always, like I
mentioned, playing with data.
You'll see that
before you log in.
But once you log in, you
sort of have a dashboard.
And this is going to be just
like a standard newsfeed--
it's based off of
things you responded to
and what you're part of.
And then up here is
where, pretty much, people
spend most of their
time-- in these five
and, primarily, these three.
Competitions-- like I
mentioned before, we'll
have a list of all
the active competition
that we have by prize.
So we have one for a
passenger screening algorithm.
This is with TSA
and the Department
of Homeland Security.
JONATHAN CHAM: Wow.
ADDISON HOWARD: You talk about
going to go to the airport,
and putting your hands
up, and spinning around
on the machine--
well, we took 3D images--
or not we, DHS did--
of users, and, basically,
strapped different objects
to their body, and
said, all right,
is there an item on this
person's lower right thigh--
yes or no?
And what is the likelihood
that there is-- yes or no?
And there's a wide
variety of competitions
that can really be interesting.
It's entirely dependent
on what your interest is,
both off of skill set--
are you interested
more in image based data?
3D imaging?
Text?
Audio?
Tabular data?
Industry-- so you
can see here, we
have things like
security, real estate.
This is Mercari.
It's, I know, expanding a
lot in the US right now.
They're kind of like an OfferUp
or a Craigslist-style app.
We have one that's image based,
that's, literally, satellites
from space saying,
here is the picture
of a ship or an iceberg?
That way, as ships are planning
their navigation routes,
they can try to better plan how
to get to certain locations.
There's really a whole
host of different things.
Recruit is a Japanese company
that is similar to in the US--
we have a Groupon, as
well as an OpenTable.
It's kind of both of those.
And they're saying,
what's the likelihood
that someone's going to go
to a restaurant today or not?
And as you mentioned,
there's a couple of fun ones.
So we have this spooky
author implication that said,
based off of people's
writing styles,
can you guess who wrote it?
Now, obviously, this one is
a little bit more for fun.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
ADDISON HOWARD: You can just
go, Google those things.
JONATHAN CHAM: But it's funny
how people are putting money
behind it, though.
I mean, it seems like someone
is funding this fun idea.
ADDISON HOWARD: So this
one, actually, we funded.
We created this one as a
playground competition.
JONATHAN CHAM: Got it.
ADDISON HOWARD: And so we don't
have an exact, quote, "winner"
on this one, because you
could just search it and put
in all the actual answers.
JONATHAN CHAM: Right.
ADDISON HOWARD: But
we have prizes of top
voted awards for best
kernels, best themes
on tutorials, discussions.
So there are other ways,
like I mentioned earlier,
that we're trying to get
people involved in that.
And like you mentioned, we
just launched a competition
yesterday.
We call it the Santa challenge.
We have a Santa
challenge every year.
It's more of a fun one.
The one this year is a little
bit less machine learning
and it's more of an
optimization type of challenge.
But it's always a
good time for us.
As you mentioned, datasets
is a pretty common way.
We're actually seeing a lot
more people come to Kaggle,
saying, I know you guys
are dataset platform,
I never heard of
your competitions.
So that's really cool
for us, as we grow.
And it's both our team
going out and finding--
as you see here, we have
over 6,000 datasets.
Actually, let's see what do
we have for the most votes.
We have everything from
credit card fraud detection--
this is a pretty common
one that a lot of people
like to have to use--
a wide variety of
clean data on movies.
So the idea is that it not only
provide you with clean data,
it provides a community
with the opportunity
to kind of see what
other people are doing,
as well as this gives you an
area to play around with things
you're interested in.
Here's one that's
European soccer,
I think there's one
that's on Pokemon,
there's one on wine ratings.
There's the Pokemon
one, right down there.
So it gives people a chance to
do some exploratory type data
analysis on their own
without any kind of--
it's more of an introductory
way to kind of play around
with stuff, because,
maybe, you don't
have the data to play around
with it or you're saying, hey,
I don't have the Bureau of
Labor statistics information
for Bulgaria for 1938 in an
easily organized fashion.
Oh, wait, but Kaggle does,
because somebody else is just
as passionate about it as
I am and they uploaded it.
So there's a lot of cool
opportunities there, as well.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
I think that's super powerful,
because, traditionally, you
don't have that amount
of available datasets
for you to actually
test your knowledge,
improve your skill
set, just sharpen
your talent in those areas,
and also just build off
a community that's able to
improve maybe what you did
and you didn't think about it.
ADDISON HOWARD: Right.
And we're starting to see
a lot of companies do--
because, as you mentioned,
we don't host competitions
that have public data,
because somebody can just go
look it up and win
the competition.
We have a lot of
people saying, we
have data we want
to just make public,
so that people can
go do things with it.
There's a lot of
companies that truly
do see the value of
publicly available data
for broader analysis.
And we're getting a lot
of that being brought
into our community as well.
And I'll touch, very
briefly, on kernels.
We kind of mentioned
this as well,
but this is a big opportunity
to share your own work.
And so, as I mentioned, the
biggest value that people see
is sort of twofold--
one is sharing, and
two is not having
to deal with downloading a
wide variety of libraries,
and versions, and languages,
and things like that.
What's very common is what
we call forking kernels.
And so somebody might have a
particular script or notebook
that they have,
but somebody else
wants to use it for
a different use case.
So for example, maybe somebody
has a McDonald's use case
and they did a Twitter
[INAUDIBLE] analysis
on McDonald's.
And somebody else says,
this is a great code
that I want to use.
I want to apply it
to United Airlines.
And they then go in and then
do that with United Airlines.
They could then copy and paste--
or rather, we call it forking--
and then, basically, just
tweak that part of the code
that they need to, to
shift that new data.
And you can see here--
I mean, some of these have
hundreds of comments that
are people talking about it.
This top one is
recently exciting.
It's been updated in
the past two hours.
Let's see if we can
get this loaded here,
in the last few
minutes that we've got.
As you mentioned, Jonathan,
it's very, very well documented,
so you see things
like people speaking
in more of a common
language, all different types
of visualizations.
Usually, you can see
some fun animation.
Sometimes people will bring
that in there as well.
So it gives people a chance
to really learn and grow
from whatever stage
of development
that you're currently in
withe machine learning.
JONATHAN CHAM: Cool.
STEPHANIE WONG: Awesome.
Well, I think that's almost
all the time we have.
Is there any other
questions from online?
JONATHAN CHAM: No.
I mean, yeah, there's some.
I guess I kind of answered
it on your behalf,
but one of the
questions was, it seems
like Kaggle's primary purpose is
to help businesses crowd source
solutions to a data
science problem,
is that a big problem
that businesses have now?
And my response was, I mean,
at least from a customer
perspective, because I work
with customers every day,
hiring ML and data scientists
is really hard, especially,
specifically, for
industry experts.
It's just not possible.
ADDISON HOWARD: Right.
JONATHAN CHAM: Actually,
we're probably taking
all of them, if possible.
ADDISON HOWARD: Yeah.
JONATHAN CHAM: So I don't know.
What is your response to that?
ADDISON HOWARD: I
think you said it well.
I think what we're seeing is
people will usually understand
ML in one of three ways--
either I hear about this,
I know I should so it, I have
no idea where to get started--
I guess the first one is, why
should I be involved in ML?
The second is, I know I
need to be involved with ML,
I just don't know
how to get started,
and three is, I know I need
to be involved with it,
I know how to get started, now
let's go use Kaggle for it.
And so I interact with
people on all three
of those different sides.
I think, for those
of us who are, maybe,
in that developer
community, it's
easy to think, what do you mean?
People don't get this?
You have no idea how many times
I have to explain to my parents
what Kaggle is and they
still don't know what it is--
or machine learning,
at the least.
It is growing so
rapidly that we have
no idea where the
saturation point, really,
is even going to begin.
JONATHAN CHAM: Well,
Addison, thank you so much
for your time.
I guess, for now, we
still have our jobs.
ADDISON HOWARD: For now.
STEPHANIE WONG: I thought
I was going to get out.
JONATHAN CHAM: You can't
go home early today.
ADDISON HOWARD: Episode
39, brought to you
by machine learning
generated hosts.
JONATHAN CHAM: Don't
say that, Addison.
STEPHANIE WONG: No, this
is the fun part of our job.
We like this.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah, exactly.
Anyway, well, thank you so much
for tuning in and thank you
for chatting.
Hit subscribe, if you
enjoyed this show.
If you didn't, hit
subscribe anyway.
And we'll see you next time.
Thank you.
STEPHANIE WONG: Bye.